- Well, your kids are both into music.
That's amazing.
I love that
- They are.
- Yeah.
- Though my daughter
just quit piano lessons.
- Oh, she did? You know what?
Hey, I quit piano.
- Did you?
- Look at me now.
- Oh, look at you.
(Angela claps)
Okay. Okay.
- Look at me now.
- Thank you for that.
- I mean,
quit and couldn't afford
are two different things,
I realize.
- Oh, I know that one.
- Yeah, I couldn't afford.
- That's why
I don't play guitar,
'cause I couldn't afford.
- Yeah, I couldn't afford,
that's why I quit.
- Yeah.
- Like also with violin.
But I quit it and look at me now.
That's why.
- Okay. Okay.
(audience applauds)
You know why?
- 'Cause, really, I was like,
"No, not everyone can play piano.
Oh, just," and then I flipped it.
It was like, "Yeah, come on down here
and be regular like us.
Come on down here with the regular people
who don't play piano."
- You should tell her this though,
'cause I am really bummed though,
'cause I could play,
and now I try and get back at it,
and if you don't.
Even if she's not taking lessons.
- Too busy.
- Just to do it for fun,
because it's a beautiful thing to have
when you're older.
- We want her to get back
to the love and the joy of it.
- Yeah.
- I was like, "Hey, all right,
you gotta have a passion
for whatever it is."
So.
- I agree.
- If it's sort of waning,
okay.
- I love it
they're into music though, that's cool.
Yeah. It's such a fun outlet.
Even if they don't do it for their career,
if they wanted it for their career,
I think it's a healthy outlet
to have something like that emotionally.
Or maybe it's just me
and my therapist said so.
(Angela laughs)
- [Kelly] Whatever.
Do you let your kids control,
like whenever you get in the
car? My kids are six and eight.
- I feel like I'm being ganged up on.
- Yeah, my kids are six and eight
and they control it.
- 16 and 16,
so I let them, you know,
on the way to school.
Yeah. Can I put on this music?
My mom wants you to hear something,
and it's like, "Ah," the assault.
Oh my gosh.
The words, it's too early for all that.
- Yeah.
I know.
- But I was surprised,
really surprised the other day,
he and I, was teaching him how to drive,
and we were talking about relationships
and you know, when you
come to the end of them
and how to handle it, or.
- Yeah.
- You know, how to be on top of it,
like if it's coming to the end, you know.
I don't wanna hang around
that sort of thing.
Just let me know if you're not interested.
Don't keep, you know, back and forth.
And so he said, "Oh, ma,
I got a song for that."
And he presses the song and out comes,
Engelbert Humperdinck's,
"Please release me, let me go."
- Oh my gosh.
- [Angela] Oh, and of course
I know the words to that,
and he's shocked at that.
I was like, yeah, "That's a oldie."
- [Kelly] Isn't that funny,
how they think they have a new song?
That happens now, and I'm like,
"I was like roller
skating to that, ma'am."
Like, I know that song.
Yeah.
- You gotta hear all
the latest and greatest,
with all the words that
a mom doesn't wanna hear.
Like put on Kidz Bop
version of that.
- Yeah. Kidz Bop.
Oh my God, my daughter hates it.
I'm always like, "You're
getting the Kidz Bop
version of that."
- Kidz Bop version of that,
you know.
- It's so funny though,
my.
- But my other play
is Sinatra.
Frank Sinatra.
- Oh, I love that.
- Yeah.
- So, I have to tell you this,
but literally I'm driving my kids
to school every morning,
and my daughter was like,
she likes this Dua Miley song, "Prisoner,"
so we play that and I'm like,
"That's cool, that's
like pop, that's cool."
My six year old son is like,
"Can you play Ray Charles,
"Hit The Road Jack?"
And I was like,
(Angela laughs)
I literally almost crashed.
I was like, "Does he listen to me
when I'm playing vinyl?"
'Cause I'm like, "How do
you know Ray Charles?"
I was like, "He's six."
I was like, I'm doing
all right as a parent,
I feel like, when one of my kids is like,
"Can you put on some Ray Charles?"
(audience applauds)
It was just so funny.
- [Angela] I remember
when mine's were like 18 months,
and I would pick my sister
up from the airport.
I would play a song
because they just listen
and absorb everything.
- Yeah.
- And so she gets in the car
and I put the song on,
and they start singing,
♪ Mr. Big Stuff ♪
♪ Who do you think you are? ♪
(Angela chuckles)
- Oh my God.
- And she's like, "Huh?"
Her mouth dropped.
- You know what though?
I play vinyl,
I think that's where they must hear it,
'cause that's where when
I play my older records.
So, I don't know, I'm gonna keep doing it.
But I was like,
that's some good music in your ear.
I love doing Miley too,
I just thought that was
more obvious for them.
- Got you.
(Angela laughs)
- I love everyone.